une ville épargnée par les bombes un
calme dont on profite comme on peut les
petites habitudes de la vie d'eve
regardez vite vous ne voyez pas la
guerre même les enfants qui semblaient
cocopaq et qui
m'est passé un peu de temps avec eux
tout vient que la sont déjà marquées par
la guerre
ils sont seuls avec leur mère installé
dans les bureaux d'un organisme des
dauphins
soixantaine d'ukrainiens chassés de chez
eux par une guerre qui n'ont pas cherché
ils sont ici temporairement désorienter
les jours perdus à tuer le teint à vivre
sans grand plaisir des vies interrompues
dans
ses valises l'essentiel pour survivre en
kit à mario paul une tente utilisée dans
les refuges sont chauffage
ce jeune homme travaillait au célèbre
théâtre de la ville c'était son deuxième
foyer il a fui mario paul juste après sa
destruction non inscrit non mais
personne n'est venu à notre secours pas
de soldes a pas de policiers pas de
bénévoles personne n'est venu dans notre
sous sol pour nous offrir de la
nourriture ou une façon de sortir de la
ville avec brio à une épreuve vécu en
couple sa compagne préfère ne pas être
filmés ou chaud le gic gratuitement et
cherchent leur avenir est solide mais
buquet ces jours ci une seule question
dans quel pays s'installer en attendant
que son conjoint puisse la rejoindre
après la guerre il faut aller vivre dans
ces pays pour quelques semaines voir
comment on aime ça est choisi je pense
que c'est la seule façon de choisir un
nouveau pays où vivre notre vie au
désarroi que cette femme comprend bien
les soldats russes ont détruit la vie de
famille qu'elles avaient lorsqu'ils ont
envahi le dombass en 2014 anan est
survenu durant les premiers mois on veut
rien bâtir on a juste besoin de se
reposer même la fin des combats ne
signale pas le retour à la vie d'avant
il faut parfois des années pour accepter
de vie ivre là où il s'était d'abord
réfugiés temporaires ba yo kempen on
préfère tous les plans que vous voulez
on en avait plein pour cet organisme
pour moi même la famille des plans pour
le printemps pour l'été mais il n'existe
plus celles ci ont fui repine défigurée
par l'artillerie russe un chez soi où
elle espère revenir un jour peut-être
mais la famille est en sécurité
l'essentiel quand les quotidiens et
pulvérisé par la guerre on m'a offert un
emploi temporaire je suis heureuse parce
que je n'aurai plus à errer dans les
rues avec mes pensées triste je peux
faire quelque chose d'utile pour
l'humanité pour moi pour le pays une
mère inquiète pour ses filles au coach
omnium dans mon champ geda difficulté à
imaginer leur avenir la plus jeune est
né en 2014 à ce moment je pouvais
l'imaginer mais après l'évasion russe je
ne peux plus faire de plan c'est le
voisin russe qui nous empêche de rêver
dans cette fois une telle fierté mieux
dans dix quinze ans est possible que mon
fils doivent aller à la guerre pour
défendre l'ukraine c'est très possible
et c'est très difficile pour moi parce
que je n'ai pas mis au monde pour qu'ils
se fassent tuer ainsi
[Musique]
le constat douloureux un drame
existentiel
devant dans l'incertitude il ne reste
plus qu'à s'accrocher aux petits gestes
du quotidien a espéré que le printemps
ramène le calme et la paix ainsi il y
avait du bon baron radio-canada ivanoff
entier